ob ich mir das jetzt glaubt oder nicht
der ist 12 hey was geht ab und bekommt
ein video jetzt wollte ich mich erstmal
wieder normal richten fachgeschäften es
geht hier ja wie man sieht ich habe mir
gedacht ja nicht kommen weil hintergrund
ist vereins ganz cool aber setzt nicht
so einfach mal aufs sofa das ist hier
ein bisschen weiter ich finde auch mehr
kohle können einen kommentar schreiben
wie ihr findet auch wenn es eigentlich
scheißegal
denn heute steht ein extrem kurzes video
an
ich habe mir schon länger mal überlegt
ich wollte immer was aber machen und
jetzt habe ich halt endlich genug
material für die viele bekommen
erst das 1 1 fiel auch schon gelesen ich
habe mir überlegt ich schlüssel einfach
mal so ein bisschen in den instagram
direkt metten gilt für meine freunde rom
die schweiz als ein bisschen englisch
auch nicht warum weiß ich auch nicht
leute ich kenne selber dass man ab und
zu mal von irgendwelchen mädchen auch
wenn man öffentlich sehen kann dass die
personen freundinnen und freunden sich
bei der nachricht so jung hielt meine
nummer schreibt mir nochmal oder sowas
gibts ja und ich würde sagen dass er bei
jung mehr ausgeprägt als bei mädchen das
es trotzdem jungs gibt die liwest auf
das ist meine freundinnen freude oder
dass ich ihre freundin aber schreibt er
trotz hin wo ich mir denke
wollt ihr mich verarschen was seid ihr
die kleine ja deswegen habe ich mir ein
paar screenshots gesammelt die schau
läuft jetzt mal zusammen an und ich war
echt geschockt was die leute daten
zeigen schreiben das ist heutzutage
einfach normal sind im jahr 2014 und das
ist anscheinend vollkommen normal ich
bin mal gespannt ob wieder feiert wenn
ihr bock hab auch noch ein teil billig
lagen bei 13.000 neigt ist das drin aber
ich will gar nicht so lang aber wir
fangen an es ist ein zwang zum teil ohne
spaß erst mal ganz locker zum anfang
hilfe was ist nichts schlimmes so mann
du bist so cups steht da mit einer
flamme und so viel herz mileys was der
sich von der nachricht jetzt erhofft
weiß ich nicht ich schaue mir einfach
mal kurz ein profil an und ja kurz
vorweg ich werde die person alle
zensieren ich habe keinen saal ob man so
noch nicht öffentlich zeigen auch
eigentlich schon so aber ich will jetzt
auch kein nervöses wenn er erst service
oder so da kommen wir gleich zu deswegen
nimmt mir das bitte nicht übel
ihr müsst die leute danach nicht hätten
oder sonstwas zustand von wegen
entwickler
das steht dir was meine deswegen ja also
hier bin ich jetzt gerade auf dem profil
von dem kleinen jungen der ist
vielleicht richten
13 und schreibt an unter seine bilder
ob ich sterbe darauf gebe ich fick das
ist der anfang von leuten die meine
freundin anschreiben mit total gestörten
sachen denn es wird noch viel viel
schlimmer als ich meinen leuten
scheidende betrifft bin ich okay danke
dass meine freundin hübsch findet okay
jetzt komm ich kurz runter
jetzt machen wir weiter und war mit
dieser nachricht einfach so ganz stumpf
zehnter februar 2017 um 23 uhr ein 20
kannst du mir ein nacktbild schicken der
was soll denn jetzt meine freundin von
mir denken die hat doch jetzt denkt doch
was ist was bist du für mensch die
widerrechtliche aussieht wie sie
vielleicht wieder wohnt keine ahnung ich
die quote auf dein profil gibt glaube
ich jetzt nicht ob mir das jetzt glaubt
oder nicht
der ist zwölf kläger du bist 12 wieso
bis zum 30 27 nachmittag mit 12 wir
haben deine eltern falsch gemacht wenn
ich befragt johann etwas zu suchen macht
mit zwölf verfahren eine hobbys ja ich
hab's gameboy gespielt ab und zu dürftig
mal bis 19 uhr aus meinen freunden
fußball spielen und wenn ich dich frage
sagte ja ich schreibe manchmal mädchen
und 53 75 jahren entschied man aktiv
nach kurzem ein kleine drehpause so da
bin ich schon wieder
ich hoffe euch geht mir nicht nur leute
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
pflegefall ohne spaß ich bin ich am
liebsten nicht zensieren ich würde ich
gerne vor diesem etat sieger den mit
100.000 menschen ich würde dich gerne
vor diesem 100000 menschen bloßstellen
weil sie so ein bisschen auf ich weiß
sagt ein freund und droht aber fündig
übel selbst ist dabei schreiben ich bin
fand ich übrigens schade kein interesse
schicke hier mal ein bild von mir
vielleicht ändert wir dann deine meinung
was diese sinnvoll spaß oder spaßig sind
vor allem steht der typ da denkst du
hast dein körper also wenn man sich so
hinstellen in dieser pose die jeder
zweite junge so hat ich weiß nicht
es ist normal dass ich mich lohnt
darüber aufregt oder ich weiß nicht was
ich dazu sagen mir fehlen die worte wenn
das heutzutage will ich würde niemals
auf die idee kommen ein mädchen an zu
schreien dass ein freund hat und dann
ein bild von mir zu schicken oben oder
sonst was wissen sie noch was es heißt
so dass nicht auch noch mal so hohe
alter was bist du für ein weltmann guckt
euch doch mal an halo 3
und jetzt dieser spruch ist dass der
engel hätten flügel
ich bin zwar älter aber anschreiben
angeht gut dabei wie auch bist du in
dein leben wird jetzt auf den kopf
gefallen und spaß hier
ob er hat letztendlich und
weihnachtliches dahinter 82 das heißt
erst jetzt rechnen ist jetzt 34 oder 35
parteien rolf ohne spaß
ich weiß ich würde so ein rollstuhl
schon häufig mal gerne begegnen wie sind
diese menschen drauf wie ich weiß ich
weiß echt nicht was soll man dazu sagen
ich kann mich jetzt über aufdringlich
stunde lang aber was bringt mir dass er
leute hier noch die letzte nachricht von
heute
das ist mein profil bild mann in rotem
zum anfang interesse melden richtig sein
freund muss ja nichts davon wissen du
kannst mir vertrauen halt dein maul du
machst
nein ich habe mich so aufgeregt ich
schwitze schon davon weil ich mich so
aufgeregt habe also können ja meinen
kommentar dazu sagt ist das normal
oder ist das jetzt 15 einzelfälle wie
ist das heute sagen dass wir nicht bei
interessierten seiten kennt ihr euch
damit auch auf das jetzt andauernd von
jungs angeschrieben werden die total ein
weg haben wenn ihr jetzt mädchen weiter
so sein sonst würde ich sagen
falls sich die situation ergibt gibt
weil 13.000 50.000 der kanal noch eine
folge von ich bin gespannt an sich ist
ja auch ganz lustig so zur unterhaltung
aber gut
wir sehen uns morgen wieder am morgen am
samstag gibt es ein neues video um 14
uhr das gänsehaut ryan clowe folgt aus
inter aber bitte nicht solche anfragen
als münchen obwohl schicken könnt ihr
das nochmal meine freundin darauf
eingehen
sex up in st wir sind tief